and we're back ladies and gentlemen it's
a Monday Brennan welcome back from
beautiful and dynamic and exciting
Cincinnati Cincinnati come on down
across the Cincinnati River I did I saw
the bridge oh good good good
now Cincinnati I think there's a way you
cross the bridge and where are you
you're in another state aren't ya
well the code is that this wake up the
tri-city try Wi-Fi tip something like
tip city something that yeah because
it's Indy what else Ohio yeah where does
do you know the where does Europe and
Asia meet anybody for 10 points where
does Europe and Asia meet it's called
Asia Minor what would that what would
that country be kids anyone anyone you
cross the Dan you you cross the danube
the Blue Danube to get into Asia and you
cross the damage and where do you hit
okay what's that and where's my question
when we go from Europe across the Danube
we rush oh-ho-ho I'm liking here
attitude and I'm liking how you're
trying I'm liking how you're trying give
me some I'm gonna give you some hints
now if we cross the danube again I sure
do like all right well let's see well
you know and you guys know I'll tell you
what here's a hint when you cross in you
can just gobble up the scenery you can
really gobble up the scenery Turkey yes
yes gobble gobble I think you know I
think some different course aid your
hand but God you know of course it
wouldn't be Japan it would be Turkey so
so with the and turkeys considered Asia
huh yeah yeah but turkeys always wanted
to be considered Europe its kind of yeah
they don't want to be overly hey they
don't really flaunt that flag done out
they want to be part of the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization oh wow do
you know you know what you did not know
that because look at [ __ ] our maps
and I don't either so I'm just as guilty
but I'm sure called you stayed the [ __ ]
out of these maps yeah you do what you
still you still forget Kyle just the I
was thinking about this last night
because thing about my son in schools
and all that
this thing about the conventional way of
they teach kids these days it's not the
route to go with it now some other
schools but you know some of them and
I'm not you know but there's something
to be said about learning on the gut you
know I'm saying like yeah if you want to
learn about Europe you go to Europe yeah
learn about the history of England you
go to England you have someone it knows
what the [ __ ] you learned you self teach
so so my one of my favorite podcast has
philosophize this and it's Stephen West
he's 30 I've turned Rogen on to him and
Roman loves him he's 30 and I I'm
telling you I've never and he came to my
show in Spokane this weekend and kind of
like a quiet guy shy and I go [ __ ]
Stephen like just even weddings yeah we
believe he's very humble we start
talking and as I'm like I was so blown
away that his age he's actually read
everything like you know it's one thing
to say you know philosophy it's nothing
to say to know exactly how it works for
their influences were and how about this
obsessional thing though you know so I
go how did you but how did you get such
a command to this because he does really
well the Pope Vlad the pop podcast kills
it so he goes I was I was basically
erased in foster care so it's 16 years
old he was out on his own and didn't
know how to make sense of the world he's
like I don't know nobody he's here to
really teach me anything so soon
philosophy became his parents so he just
started reading and he never stopped
reading identified with that damn and I
like how it's only 22 minutes long is
what I mean
if these short little nuggets you get
start listening to it it's a great
podcast he makes it so easy I'm
Nietzsche
you don't want to know about Nietzsche
you shut in 22 minutes hell yeah I do
write but don't you think be like you
know like if you think about the way
you're educating high school and college
I come down like I didn't learn anything
I learned how to pass tests right like I
studied just as soon as I passed the
test
gone exactly so you picked up some of
those nuggets from the basics but
they're not making it relevant right it
doesn't relate to you like especially
this day's world it's just not right
like what the only time that math I got
kind of good at math it was only because
my father said it teaches you how to
think and it'll teach you how to debate
effectively would you mad
but I was like oh that's ham oh okay
I'll use that you know science if that's
what you're into you've kind of got to
go to class but yeah yeah no I like
Falacci with the in technology smart
people sat around and thought about
things but there's that new type of what
they call it it's a new type of way they
teach where the kids aren't there the
math really isn't involved in what
science technology stem yeah technology
hits do that yeah this office team that
includes the arts - Bryce team you need
a nice team I think I'm a huge believer
in the arts yeah for sure
exercise imagination that's my favorite
cuz I could have done it all over again
I would have played the piano and danced
but then I probably like oh I wish I
wrestled you'd suck more [ __ ] uh-huh
what what where support yeah there's a
bunch of these things popping up but
higher education like no I don't want
him go for what I want but I'm Tigers
older I think he's gonna be able to get
everything he needs online I really do I
think I think he's gonna change the
world especially is our College system
high school soon and listening college
all about money man oh then besides like
we don't really give a [ __ ] where you
went to college like I have friends who
graduate college they get done like then
help me man you know when you go to high
level either these networks is because
network network exactly thought it was
networking exactly that's it it's people
you know who are already in power yeah
and then you can get a job otherwise
otherwise yeah it doesn't make a lot of
sense
this guy this guy wrote a book called
excellent excellent sheep and he taught
her all the Ivy League schools and he
was like here's the problem is these
kids grow up thinking about nothing
other than getting into a college so
what they do is they only do [ __ ] that
they're good at but they can be really
good at a bunch of stuff they'll be good
at violin and they're good but they're
there they do the light as good as
jumping through hoops when they have a
curriculum and to pass the test
yes passing the test of getting into
college getting good grade we don't have
that one guy test right when you when
you have to make your own test when you
have to make your own book they're in
trouble I was watching this thing on a
free watch station but they were saying
how like high school kids getting jobs
are so low like the pool for kids
getting jobs because in ice throw every
something you have to work right yeah
doesn't sports but I [ __ ] had a jock
they're saying the the the younger kids
now they're not in summer jobs you know
what they're doing they're trying to do
stuff they're going back to doing summer
school they're doing other activities
that make their college resumes look
exactly but that is not exactly have you
seen this [ __ ] that documentary the
inventor with Elizabeth Holmes no oh
what's it on it's on HBO oh say no more
fm mmm dude
so check her out first first first bring
her up maybe and just that just if you
could so she I remember 19 years old
starts a company it goes up to ten
billion over ten billion dollars she's
gonna take a tiny vial at the old
redhead yep I'm gonna take a droplet of
blood this big and put it into a machine
called the Edison I'm gonna and we put
in the Machine and it's gonna give you
our full readout you can do it at home a
whole run Adam it will give you a full
run that sold to Walgreens and we will
tell you everything you need to know
about your health in a droplet of blood
okay
never mind that's impossible for a
thousand physiological reason sold it
Bill Clinton interviewed er bring up
Clinton interviewing Elizabeth Holmes
wait how does no scientist kill well
that's not well so ready so this is the
greatest thing about it so here she is
Steven jobs is her fan she wore the same
outfit every day so she didn't have to
think about anything else and she's
there oh you mean she has no style
that's what that means well did she did
no clue Steven jobs did that Steven jobs
oh no the head on the screen yeah I got
one better no chill square that square
sign I've ever seen in my life
oh he's a human leg go bring her up on
the TED Talks I want to hear talk just I
want him to hear her voice oh this I
remember briefly but some there's
something bad bad around her right I'll
tell you oh I'll tell you so anyway she
starts company at 19 years old she
raises 10 it's a 10 billion dollar
company right there ten billion dollars
all right
she she she's got everybody on her board
the individual in changing outcomes no
unless say I'm I dig in it have access
to do so she is dressed like Bruce Wayne
to lower her voice right to protect the
rate to protect
and well-being the well-being every
person smart girl though calculators we
love killer oh why because she had
everybody to Ditka so okay so that's
good so now check this out so she's a
superstar she's in every magazine this
is ten years she creates theranos in
Silicon Valley right in here Tesla she's
got she's got the advisors the initially
the guy who was the first investor in
Skype Tesla Airbnb Twitter other this
huge better
he was like his daughter went to school
with her and at Princeton so she drops
out of her hands and he's like all of us
in your company you're a visionary
everybody's involved right next thing
you know there's this they're this it's
a it's a machine it's called the
Edison's this big after Thomas Edison
say your whole read out the problem was
that it was all under all this secrecy
so you had to go through five doors and
said amazing doesn't say scientist
they're like so the scientists were all
like told what to do but they can't talk
about there either
all these he's got these powerful
attorneys meanwhile she's trying to make
fake it till she makes it look at how
small that droplet of blood is so all of
a sudden these journalists start doing
things on they go well how does the
machine work well through
miniaturization and southern bagel yeah
but this is comically vague some real
smart people out there man you can't
honey didn't know so this Wall Street
Journal [ __ ] and investigative
journalists because I smell [ __ ] I
smell [ __ ] long story short that
company was a huge sham it was all fake
they'd be Latino scientists with
scientists were like you want us to tell
people this stuff but that we're I can't
do this this machine's not working
no no that knew how the machine was
working I know this isn't working people
were getting other labs that mystery but
they were and the whole house this woman
so happened to all she had 700 employees
all credible scientists one guy like
killed himself because he didn't want to
he didn't he - he's people he's just
found out that it was all [ __ ] and
he's gonna have to go testify holy I was
this greatest documentary ever well dude
you got to see it meanwhile that that
woman is going to jail now I believe for
life no life does she deserve
yeah why cuz she's a huge scam artist
and she was using real people and using
real patients she's kind of a [ __ ]
life Toby twenty years a fine of two
hundred thousand dollars each count of
wire fraud she's potential to Boyd two
to five million dollars Horne and her
company's worth billions
sprite ball not anymore oh it's worth
exactly zero she's got no money she was
just a shyster Wow
but man did she really have a good run
there she had a good run yeah i popping
bottles and [ __ ] yeah wow it sounds like
his great documentary did you see the
one on there uh nuh I love you now die
know about the girl with her boyfriend
and he want to commit suicide she texts
him text them into it and he does it and
she's under and they go to court did she
did she murder him I love you now die
hit though what was what's the most nine
disturbing things I think it's what do
you think be so hon let me let me paint
the picture here before you since you're
on that last document for me I don't
need to see it now it was for you well
know you covered every I'm good now
though this one's same thing 214 I think
that should happen so I'll cover it so
you don't have to watch it so this
Michelle Carter she's kind of like she's
super neat he has no friends really she
meets this boy on family vacation they
live like I don't know a few hours away
from each other they start texting they
get in a relationship
homeboy has tried to commit suicide four
times before I'm ever meeting her he
suffers from it and he would they would
go back and forth and he would almost
harass or with his with his depression
and like with commit suicide and so she
thought she was helping him by tell him
to do it she's like well if this all you
want [ __ ] genius there's no
responsibility don't think so no I do
that's that's what that's what the court
and the the Boston legal system deal
with because I think is bazan because
Boston Massachusetts because they were
trying to figure out like is she the
reason why commit suicide the parents
blamed her everyone blame her
this kid was clinically depressed and
had a major problem what for time would
I don't blame somebody who was probably
really
fed up and like Jesus Christ dude do it
already if you keep [ __ ] talking to
me about this or whatever it is it is it
she's allowed to say whatever the [ __ ]
she wants I mean I
but he's is the same as like if you tell
me you're gonna if you're a child with
this you're a child and you do that but
if you're an adult if you're a
consenting adult and you're influenced
by that I don't know how you hold this
other person accountable because you
don't know what the context was right
she might be a size sociopath or she
might have been really frustrated and
been like no sure this shoe I think it
was both I think it was both because
yeah because she was like hey when you
die can can I tell everyone like you
were my boyfriend and he's like yeah
sure and then she like held this is so
[ __ ] up she held like like a
fundraiser but in her home town and all
his friends like why the [ __ ] you do it
there she's like well cuz all my friends
are here you know not his hometown so
she just wanted to like get Fame up yeah
I mean so so what we're doing is we're
we're we're blaming her for murder
because she's not sensitive she may not
have loved the guy anymore
she made it aside this guy's a [ __ ]
mess and I just can't do this and I'm
not in love and I know I don't like this
but it was also what he wanted you know
I'm saying but this is where it's not
you can't save somebody I try to say
look I all due respect to everybody
who's committed suicide in their
families cuz it's horrible I tried to
save somebody from committing suicide
but they want to do it then they did it
right and they did it and I really tried
I [ __ ] tried and it was awful and
I've never told the story and I and I
don't just because it doesn't matter but
the point is is that I remember thinking
to myself and I said to my friend I said
I did everything I could and my friend
said you know you there's nothing you
can do and it's really hard sometimes
but that's like me trying to save my
girlfriend from being a drug addict it's
like you trying to stop me from eating
carbs I can't do not not happen yes I
can try man
so you know do you that what do you
think what's your take on this you some
documentary yeah I don't she definitely
shouldn't go to prison but I think did
she got it yeah she did a year and a
half not terrible kind of slap on the
wrist she got way hotter does she got
can eat anymore but but 8but Chia so big
ha
hey buddy here shoots do you know how
much life
here's the thing is he so he get he does
it he puts the thing the ventilation
into the truck you know to die that way
so remember this is his fifth attempt
now so he's not very good at so this is
his fifth attempt he does it this way he
gets scared that he's gonna die he's
texture-wise doing this he's in the
truck so he buys the machine all himself
she has nothing that she won't give
money he does all this himself sets
everything up goes in the truck gets
scared when he's about to commit suicide
gets out of the truck Tech sir I can't
do this she checked him back yes you can
get back in that [ __ ] truck and then
he does it I still don't think it's I
still don't I call her motive a oh I a
still I still don't think she she has to
go do you think that I don't know that's
tough I mean I really don't know
honestly I don't think I don't think I
know enough I don't think she bears
responsibility I don't think you can
it's a very slim zero we like you but is
it her spot cuz she told the police or
the family or I again I don't know what
that relationship was like right so
sometimes my cyber right was a cyber
relation yeah they might have been in a
fight she's nothing well she's not doing
great
you know they plan no she's tribal no
you know what I mean she messed to he'll
agree I breath she's got me this [ __ ]
everybody
I'm telling cuz she can't eat she was
thick and then she got she's so like
stressed about going to [ __ ] prison
for life she got super thin horrible
what she went through I need that man
when he gets stressed out but I I think
it's really easy to try to make somebody
a victim I mean a villain but I this
one's pretty bad but it's a two-part see
she watched the first part it basically
shows how bad she was and I was it ghost
but she's got a prison for life then you
see the second part you see how [ __ ]
up he was yeah and how he's always
wanted to do this and his photos she
like as a person though she's not good
she wants fame from him commit suicide
she she pretty went missing for like
three days that's not a jailable offense
I know but listen is B no no that it's
capable but she she went missing for
like three days and then she just to get
attention she'd have many friends I felt
bad for her but she was super needy
just to get attention she told our
friends that he commits suicide so she
did like a trial run to see how
and she got ton of attention and she's a
cold [ __ ] he popped up yeah I was like
all preconceived yeah she's got problems
she's got problems but that's all she
has horrible problems what what is what
was she a con what does she know oh
she's a high school it did yeah I'm like
softball yeah so IIIi think this is a
tragedy in all cases all the way around
here's the text message you just need
you to do it Conrad the more you push it
off the more it will eat at you you
ready and prepared all you have to do is
turn the generator on and you be free
don't spell be like that and you be free
and happy no more pushing it off no more
waiting if you want it as bad as you say
you do it's time you do it today so that
sounds bad if you don't know the context
the problem is is this [ __ ] want
it so bad yeah like he kept trying to do
it [ __ ]
I think - I got alright dude we'll
[ __ ] do it man like bought all this
stuff all you want shut the [ __ ] up
about it just do it it's a very strange
kick cuz like it's a little different in
dr. Kevorkian right because those people
were suffering Oh
suffering huh yeah like and you can't
you can't break a promise just go in a
quiet parking lot or something and then
nothing she was but she did want it
seems my back you trying to do it today
or what she sounds like she happy it
sounds like she's gonna get fetish yeah
well she knows using it fame from yeah
and she's a terrible person she wanted
him to dodge a terrible person so so I
would say that she's a [ __ ] or she's
a very confused messed up young lady
here the Tecla just cute look oh here
you go and are you the homeboy well this
is 545 they haven't spoke all day he
types in how do daysius what are you
gonna do yes and you'll get snap chain
where I sent them to my day was he good
she goes that's great what did you do
and I'm just going to work a little bit
then look for stuff what are you gonna
do it stop ignoring the question you
can't think about it you just have to do
it you said you were gonna do it like I
don't get why you art because I don't
get it either
I don't know [ __ ] man then she goes so I
guess you aren't gonna do it then no
[ __ ] for you all that for nothing I'm
just confused like you were so ready and
determined alright I mean eventually he
goes I mean I mean
around to it I don't know what I'm
waiting for but I have everything lined
up no you're not Conrad you predict last
night was it you just kept pushing off
and you say you're gonna do it but
you're never gonna do it so it's gonna
be that way if you don't take action
sounds like a motivator to me you're
just making it harder on yourself by
switching off you just have to do it do
you want to do it now he goes is it too
late I don't know it's like it's already
light outside I'm gonna go back to sleep
love you I'll message you tomorrow no
it's probably the best time now because
everyone's asleep just go somewhere in
your truck no one is really out right
now because it's awkward time if you
don't do it now you're never gonna do it
and you can just say you'll do it
tomorrow but you probably won't alibi yo
you awake hours are you gonna do it
today hours like now that person now I
kind of exaggerated some of that test
I just gives you the context she's she's
a that's bad guy if I were her family if
I was his family I would want her dead
oh they do they want her in prison for
yeah but she's but she sounds like a
sociopath who you know it sounds like it
sounds like she was getting off on
having enough power to get somebody to
kill but she's also she like she even
has a voice in high school she was like
everyone picked on her like she had no
friends so all the kids like she's super
choose to me so there's something wrong
with her oh yeah right I mean so this is
somebody who's got their own mental it's
like the to the the processor and
outside the defense is kind of alibi was
like hold on if he was gonna he's tried
to commit suicide four times if he was
in commit suicide and she's walking by
if she yelled do it now jump harder as
hard as you can should she go to prison
no he was gonna do it no matter what
yeah but to encourage him to do I mean
you're not a complete [ __ ] no no no
he's not girl who's 18 or 17 I think
she's 16 at that okay so she's a child
she's she's clearly very some keeps
going down chin her so there's one
really bad something's wrong with her
right something's wrong with her she
wanted attention
look this [ __ ] well she's relentless
yeah he was hams going on a walk shoes
are you back from your walk he goes in
like five minutes she goes okay so are
you gonna do it yes Jesus I guess she
was what's that me goes I don't know I'm
freaking out about it you know what now
I'm reading these texts
like he might have not done it if she
wouldn't [ __ ] kept encouraging it so
much right
she's the Robins a suicide she just
[ __ ] motivate him so much I don't
know I think it drives me crazy more you
seen you do a con right Ari I'm gonna do
it today you feel bad for the kid man
promise or she ever shaken and then
she's telling where to go go somewhere
you know what you won't get caught you
can find a place are you gonna do it now
he was I'm determined and she goes I'm
happy to hear that he goes I'm ready
good because it's time you know that
when you get back from the beach you're
just gonna go do it it's the best time
to do it
are you back yes no more thinking just
have to do it on my way
Kmart parking lot there's gonna be no
cars there at 9:00 so that's where I'll
be found okay perfect when will you be
home and like 10:00 what a sad story
like I don't want to kill anyone else
with me you won't when they opened the
door they won't know it's color
swordless you're thinking again oof oh
wow so this this is a 16 year old who
had no idea this is all gonna be on the
record and ruined her life and there's
something your life should be a little
ruined you know I can't do this this is
a mentally unstable girl and and the boy
was unstable these are two very unstable
people Wow I was trying to do it so
she'd get attention how terrible is this
her life he goes I just don't know how
to leave the family she goes see you and
go the store he was know like I want
them to know that I love them and I
didn't mean to hurt them she goes yeah
the probably sat for a while but they
get over it you know you had no other
choice
she's a kid though she doesn't know this
is this is 16 year old baby but this is
my I know that's a defense I wasn't like
that man no one in the room was like
because because you didn't suffer from
some kind of behavioral disorder or
meant I don't know dude I think saying
that well they're just a kid they don't
know I disagree especially at 16 I knew
not to drink and drive I knew not to
rape girls
I knew if homeboy was gonna commit
suicide don't talk them into it yeah you
know I'm saying yeah there's the lost
once he was leaving now okay you can do
this I'm almost there did you delete the
message Conrad Conrad Conrad
and the next post enjoy the parade from
up there tomorrow Conrad know you would
love to be there each that is just in
this [ __ ] posted I will never
understand why this had to happen
natural suicide awareness day I wish
more people understood I love you know
she's she's a terrible person was her
way of becoming popular for once
alright well that's the documentary in
Adachi yeah okay she goes prison for
about two years
um it's just a bummer man I think yours
is better
who's more sick at the head least your
girl is smart about it who created the
Aizen what was it the Edison to Edison
[ __ ] heads yeah again that's not
yours
how about your along sixteen-year-old
you know how about your girl its prison
longer though well yeah but this is a
sixteen year old so a lot of times
that's taken into account it's very sad
you know that's a bummer
yeah there are a lot of people who like
dogs we don't do it try to figure out oh
no that's gonna help me I'm glad you
said that though yeah let's turn this
thing to comedy don't do this don't do
this text Bryan Callen dude you went to
a spoke in a can nice room right well
and I'm I wanna great here he wants to
retire in Coraline daddy want smooth
you're about the age dude you know I'm
wit to Coral and when I'm with my place
safe together I got to be over fifty
gotta be able all that legal late age
there fifty probably I'll tell you what
got Wolves got got Grizzlies guy was
like I love when I you know those guys
you do the this real sweet guy his name
is Larry and he's a bouncer shadows
Larry and at the club such a good guy
just this giant dude yeah he's real
spirit but he's like the kind of guy who
was like he let he was a fan and he he's
you know and you go there and people are
have pride in their hometown ya know
that he goes uh I got that they got
things you something about hiking is
yeah watch F the gorillas you Grizzlies
I was like you got Chris oh yeah they
come down to eat the huckleberries ooh
and I go really and he goes have you at
huckleberries
no no and he goes oh dude they're like
blueberries but wild it's like then the
other guy goes oh yeah huckleberries
another guy goes sorry guys he goes
huckleberry do you can get you can get a
bucket for like 30 Bobby loves their
huckleberry I'll be a common walk down
this guy was a hunter there there and he
goes um he has a camera thing I mean you
just show me all the wolves that would
go by just spoke in a nice little area
[ __ ] yeah
down telling it's OCD at night whatever
with a drug addicts a lot of meth and
smoke a lot of math a lot of heroin yeah
see that a lot that something about
British Columbia Vancouver Seattle
Portland Portland Spokane a lot of
heroin a lot of meth a lot of missing
teeth a lot of walking zombies I think
that is I don't know I think because
those cities are very very lenient and
they provide services all right so you
have services also it's always cloudy so
you depressed I don't know that is weird
and they're super is they're pretty
harmless they're kind of addicts who
like apologize for bothering you and
then do like they know they know that
you don't have any money
yeah yeah yes but got a good you love
you there a lot of good rusty good
restaurants Cincinnati yeah yeah I know
I know I know about Cincinnati I know
about Cincinnati that the worst beats of
my life I know about cincy good Club
though right
good Cloney branwall random 8-ball not
so big big bigger club was I say wet oh
god six years ago bigger club if this
one's only been open for three years
gotcha
you might have went to different clubs
my choice one's an old clock no so in
seats about five hundo that's a big
clock game perhaps are all well this is
a listen improv this would be a coal
bananas
comedy zone okay yeah yeah funny bone
sorry funny emcees since the pretty
funny bone it's ran really well and
actually it's not in Cincinnati
it's it no it's in welcoming our boy go
back for a second go back to the next
page can we get our boy what's his name
up where is he it's a girl
no this guy down here that I owe your
boy that matters I accident carry on
yeah you know what I love Gary let's get
him on yeah man oh I
Carrie I feel bad that I you should made
him I said some [ __ ] he's hilarious
actually think about it I don't know
about how I said bad I didn't mean to
and nobody forget people are listening
and he's a good effort by all accounts I
hear he's a great guy so I want to make
it right um okay if you if you ate
somebody tweeted Gary why don't you do
it yourself dude okay I don't depend on
the fans yeah just do Tom super when he
was younger go back up
Tom was thick no no he's younger they
have one grown look at in their far
right oh that's him jeez get look at
what's the second one bottom row
[Music]
hilarious hilarious like him with a
beard yeah it looks good with a beard so
Jay looks better with a bear - who Jay
your brother yeah yeah way better with a
thick bit oh yeah can you grow a beard
chin now wish I really do wish yeah
beards are good he grows thick but not
like fit you can grow thick thick thick
but it's gray so do you look away older
huh way older yeah I just have you look
sick dude
just a man beard could be cool yeah I
just would like to have my like my hair
grow a little older teen gonna happen
no gonna happen by now maybe technology
a pickup but I'm due to hop out um yeah
here's just alright go back let me see
my body there hold on why did chin
Google all right that right there look
at no no the next yeah let me see it
does unbroken dude whoa dude daddy gets
not fat for no daddy's cut up
daddy's pretty cut up yeah well pologize
for those abs hey daddy was talking to
some certain strength coaches and
doctors daddy in spoken no no no in Los
Angeles I hear anavar is the [ __ ]
non-toxic get you thick I could put on
about 70 pounds of muscle maybe a little
testosterone - I've been doing some
research on the old Anna bar I can't
wait to get on an ax bar testosterone it
have been
I'm not familiar anavar I'm gonna be a
good-looking deer dude animal I heard
that with female Instagram models yes
and a bra spitters CrossFitters do it
too now can you get any really good it
will cut you you'll lose weight
oh it's [ __ ] it's non-toxic I talked
to the guy who knows this [ __ ] like dong
Zi no no no it works with all the
athletes and everything I need you know
trust me and it's it's Santa bar what
about all the CrossFitters hold on let's
see what it is this is what's it say
here what is antibiotics grow up Anna
bars a pillow oral it's a pill which
supposed to be really hard on your liver
now actually this is not this debuted it
debuted in the 60s 70s Empire okay since
80s
however available more really online I
keep scrolling down what's the end of
our pill look like well definitely want
to buy that bottle keeps going down why
is it risky to buy any kind of
well-known results well this that's a
guy get see these aren't just what the
doctor Bryce told John so that guy there
before it's just just and then he's
getting ready for a competition
he's dieting and I don't care about
being kind I want to just problem muscle
see I was trying to get shrimp try out
your muscles I don't like that allows
veins to pop out we're but where does it
say non-toxic it doesn't it I was
talking to the doctor I was talking and
of are side effects go down yeah let's
see that lipids shut down unit liver
tocsy it's not very liver toxic yeah as
long as you stay off the ball and drink
a lot of water it should be okay oh well
that's not bro science at all you should
be okay interesting
baby daddy might have to touch it daddy
let's go let's do let's do let's [ __ ]
and double up on some tests and some
anavar dude come on fine I cannot test
yes it has to make you real thick it
well yeah you don't want straight
testosterone I don't think I don't know
man how you know I don't [ __ ] about
steroids I don't either
anabolic steroids anavar helps really
know who I'd get in of our from do you
know one person you can get it from oh
yeah doctors oh I know a couple
dr. I know a couple doctors testosterone
right you do a whole panel and you they
look at your thing and you start very
small and you do I think it's like eight
weeks on can you imagine it if I get my
eyes done and I'm on anavar dude okay
who's the thirty year old dude who's
gonna stop you bro my back is gonna be
sick sick with it I just can't nothing's
better when guys want to do it when guys
are in steroids and they have acne all
over the back and well yeah I broke out
at 45 bags dude I would do some anaphora
anavar and testosterone let's do it I
think we should do it honey but if I had
a good doctor was like yeah dude this
will shred 20 pounds off you and you can
get shredded I would do it you I don't
want to get bigger no I won't take
anything that's gonna make know anavar
would be good for you do buddy talk to
me in the end of our bro did come on I
bet you'd look great on Adam or you
would shred the [ __ ] up - here's my
thing I don't want to go through a
doctor I don't want to sit down and act
it I'm you know what I would like to do
I would like to sit down with a doctor
just to figure out what's good for my
body and what's not as far as diet why
it's like you to a tea instead of just
the guessing game I don't want to see a
difference all these guys are shredded
this isn't gonna work my God look at
like say I don't like care about that
maybe all it should do an abundant cat
yeah positive
I felt much more powerful yes more
confident lunar drone the more autonomy
okay that's a torsion they can actually
smell it on you well this is complete
bro science better work I got a work
ethic oh yes sir adjust that batter my
skin even look better yeah cuz that a
certain glow with the zits uh busting
dude I'm so psyched
makes me hungry hey good here's a bad
side effect I got really hungry and
shredded and I thought I bust food
insects
facial water oh I had what they call
gear face oh no wow your god my face
does not get any more bloated only
happen at first cycle though
take the number three in tents out of
nowhere
Gretchen hey it's Delroy Drage my bed I
was gonna say yeah no thanks don't
trample on test oh I like wine too much
yeah well no what would happen for
getting some anavar what if I just get
shred say again dude you'd get shred
city I don't think so please do God just
look exactly the same but more bloated
now I'll please to it you'll shred the
[ __ ] I think you'd make my appetite
through the roof I'd get to 300 pounds
I think you'd get so shredded funny I'd
be so happy and we'd be like Brendan I
can see veins for the first time do it
please you do it first be the canary in
the coal mine all right damn your boy
all right damn if you can get in anavar
make sure it's real I don't know why I
had several points trigger on any of
this stuff you know like dick stays hard
I'm fine
would you all you think about you dick
dude yeah you don't [ __ ] with the
chemistry they'll kiss good [ __ ] up your
dick Siamese well shut your age I don't
want to say my energies good I know you
don't [ __ ] with your inner sister I know
cuz I feel like I've been blessed with a
shouldn't even heard of steroids
no not yet all right wait heavy you guys
did test your testosterone we talked
about this before I haven't done it'll
forever I'm gonna test your load on your
normal Brian oh yeah what are you gonna
go to do it huh we're gonna have a whole
thing I do we'll do together I know
exactly how to do it
all right I'm down okay I hate good
insurance yeah just go do it okay so
let's check out everything so there's
testosterone that that's there are
different Reed's right so you can't just
read one level there's the testosterone
that's freakish you use and all that
stuff it's a it's a science it's a
complicated science don't you want you
didn't do anything to lose all that
weight changes to natural you just stuck
with creative or stopped eating it's
easier said than done in it it's
actually easy after a while you know
what like the first week like I'm
starving but in your stomach and bodies
go this is life exactly and then it
stops a good end reckon I'll put you on
tests wrong first check your mercury
levels high mercury a lot of fish can
bring your testosterone way down I just
not being fish and so can i it's
can like an ear like if your sink and
different vitamin D levels are a little
off that can also have an affair no but
hey doctor you sleeping I know but hey
got stuff yeah give me the [ __ ] ya know
and I'll get you where you need to end
Nana
hey Doc more sleep oh I'm not come back
here every [ __ ] day give me the [ __ ]
he says now I'm not doing no patient
yeah no no no give me the I also don't
want to shoot things in my ass hey I
don't care give me the [ __ ] you do yeah
I'm not going don't tell me eat more
tomatoes and give me the [ __ ] just shoot
if we undo this give me the [ __ ] but but
if I could just tell you me give me the
[ __ ] okay that's fine I inject in my
eyeball
listen I'm a doctor and I need to tell
you shoot it into my dick oh my god
why is your eye can't do a thing where
they inject like like a little capsule
on you and releases this yes flow
release so you'd have to shoot yourself
oh look either way either my friend my
friend who's my age are a little younger
he goes dude you wanted to testosterone
ago why goes because I've always wanted
traps my whole life let's get traps
that's a bummer
I'm like we are both losers to be
talking this way yeah there's a pill
where they do yeah you're gonna doctor
and they inject it yeah better to do in
Jack because it's less hard I want to go
to the dog no tape what's not gonna blow
up my face I can't have that yeah and
what's not gonna [ __ ] up my date game
that's the other thing yeah I can't wait
telling me I'm never gonna do it but
yeah seriously why are all the we I'm
afraid I may get my eyes done though
women are yeah but then this plastic
surgeon looked at me cuz he's my cousin
came to my show he's my plastic so he's
a plastic surgeon in Florida and he
spend the two of my shows and he goes he
said to his wife he goes he may need a
brow lift and that's a lot more
complicated and I was like well that's
never a breath
I'm never brow lifting oh now I'm
surprised oh hey don't say that I may
have just excess skin that they can take
off hey what a hound dog come on don't
upset your slowly turn the human sharpen
no no no I'm like it a few lifts just to
cut I bet that's so intense because they
can't just do here it has to be all up
here dude who isn't I just saw had it
done it oh you can tell John Travolta's
been dude I told you I've told this
story before I used to
this boss that I worked for he made
energy drinks forget his name but he got
a facelift B he had a facelift and you
know when they do it they they cut here
around the ears when they lift the face
yeah so he he came to this party like
three days after you have this facelift
so it's fresh and it's wet I can see the
stitches we try putting makeup over but
it doesn't one [ __ ] wet stitches we
saw like this rich dude yeah we know you
don't know him this one I was in
Colorado Wow I know yes I know I've told
straight a long time we're on the
podcast but he just got the facelift he
had all these young girls and I was
working as one of the like promotional
guys there's all these hot girls and he
gets in like make a big scene about it
it was so embarrassing that think about
it we're in Vegas and this one girl goes
Richard and runs for it and everyone's
like it's one on a dance program I was
like what and he has a mic and fan she
jumps on him and he's like boom baye
baye baye baye and can't hold her and
she goes no and no huge Krabs's here's
grabbed his his well he just had a wet
facelift
so his ear goes i can't can't support a
whole human body no G juice no juice
well yeah once all the way down here go
to blood alive party over party over all
right
I had seven mint mojitos that night
because they have the sugar cane the
stain I kept chewing on him I will never
forget that
hey yet believe he scores he had early
because his face fell so everyone's
there for half an hour he comes with
this fresh wet face and up everyone's
like oh my god definitely had to work
done and he gets on the mic because I
wanna thank you Ron this year's gonna be
a big year then q Richard beeline you
get the lease it to be rushed to the
emergency room oh no pretty cool though
man but normals you know I lose your
face keep on truckin you know keep yeah
I'll never forget that down there dude
there goes your ear it was bobbing
someone's ear off is easier than ripping
your ears off buddy you can rip somebody
zero oh yeah thinks barely so she'd get
old yeah his off guys never forget as
long as I live I forget a lot of things
man
but not that look at that guy's eyes
they're so youthful look so he just
looks surprised all right like you don't
wanna bring up John Travolta don't look
like you're surprised all the time yeah
oh [ __ ] why did he do that well because
what happens is these morons start will
excuse me facial at least way better its
facial hair but the hair you know well
it's the it's the forehead oh my god his
oh that's the that's the that's a far
head the far right the worst movie I've
ever seen
and that'd be when he did daddy yeah but
don't do that to your far head dude well
where did he hide his hairline delay
well yeah [ __ ] that's tough don't dye
your hair like that just be older holy
oh he did oh you got a hole here
transplant now that might be for our
part yeah he has a lot of hair on the
left yeah I don't think all he was
balding for I was balding yeah there's a
big pair of it yeah but they're not a
shaved his head entirely which is good
he shaves his entire lean then he wears
a piece that's a piece that's a glue he
doesn't like Piven smell dude I think he
finally just said screw it so he has a
shaved head looks better body please
yeah yeah dad bud dad bots are in you
know dad bods are like the thing right
now
how about people were [ __ ] body
shaming [ __ ] Jason Momoa and I
tweeted this I might if people are fat
shaming Jason Momoa the rest of us ash
oh [ __ ]
he's a grey body oh yeah who is fat
shaming him the internet in pots no
vanilla the internet was Jason Momoa dad
bought no way yeah he looks so good
though you saying he did or does it he
does he still looks so he looks fine
there yeah yeah that's a real dad bot
well they're mad they're actually they
look like Aquaman on the right yeah
that's a piece that's a you know I hate
to tell you the walk does it done the
walk the rock doesn't walk around like
that that's turning movie sets man you
don't see with a shirt off all the time
like you can't sustain that all the time
it still looks great
they look Jimmy I'd die for that body
I told you when I met him I was with
Frank Grillo a long time ago and I was
just sitting there I said one thing no
but I was like I said it Franco that's
about something I've ever seen in my
life is that is that the coolest looking
human being you've ever seen at six
before and I mean that he's a little
thicker I hear you I hear you dudes all
right there than 15 years ago when
nobody knew you know my thing is though
how you gonna body shame this dude well
because they're mad he doesn't look like
this like it's your movie but it's the
same thing who talked about that the guy
who played in 300 Oh
our driver rod Butler was saying how you
know I was such an iconic movie role for
him and then what 15 years later he
obviously doesn't look like the [ __ ]
Spartacus where the [ __ ] his name is
lien is Leonidas so he goes on these
dates and go in the room with a girl she
like what the [ __ ] dude think 300 Mitch
that wasn't [ __ ] yeah I'm sorry you
know I don't know what's going on the
right there but I don't know what it is
but I know what the left is yeah but
it's so weird like that's him one is
right you was shred City that's him
getting ready for 300 though yeah yeah
can't stay 300 specially unless you're a
professional athlete why would you blow
up do life is tough man father time does
you know what dude no you can't keep
burning weight like that you can't keep
doing that
how nice would it be if there's just a
pill that just burn everything off all
the time there is it's called anavar do
it god you're really dude you're
convincing me bro
just get one see I look like down the
riot that was like on the left yes you
look like the guy on the Left dude come
on dude all right all right wait DME
with an ax bar DME with an amazing what
you can change it what's crazy meets
homie Brad Pitt's got the [ __ ] [ __ ]
going on in Troy come on he's always
good-looking though I can't wait for
that Hollywood movie I mean either it's
gonna be good yeah the human body will
it's called the entropy things mix
unless you got good genetics man he's
tiny there though yeah went like 167
pounds yeah yeah cuz everyone goes like
in Fight Club like perfect bodies Brad
Pitt and Brad Pitt had to tell he's like
that's a hundred sixty four pounds on
that set he just shred it but people
think that's like the ideal body but
he's super skinny in like he's real he's
a thin booty he's an ectomorph yes he
actually is usually like you and Brad
have the same genetics for sure dude
yeah yeah hundred percent yeah
you're both active like you look like
you could easily cut a fight yeah I
don't think y'all look what she died it
for that roll dude right wait he also
did other stuff but I'm not not but why
not why not it's right what are you
talking about if I I would love an
excuse to go on anavar I need to do you
think that well it might be Fight Club -
you know what all I need to give me one
excuse to go on Ana mark just give me
one oh dude give me one [ __ ] Ruiz one we
to get shredded Oh cuz whatever I'm
doing now I don't have a reason I know I
have no work in situ but I want one I
thought seeing the other shredded dad
that more you could you would get you'd
be I'd be very instant see what you look
like it's not my genetics me my brother
in copper talking about this like even
when I mean I'm talking I was running
[ __ ] dude when I first started fighting
I was 200 I was 228 pounds and I was
running non-stop it's just not in my DNA
to be together that's mo I'm German
Nadia I mean it's rock Samoan it's just
not in my DNA
well rock I'm just not a yeah but still
even when he did it I'm just not like
like a ripped it's just not my genetics
it's in David Hasselhoff I think you
could do it dude I think if we get you
on anavar and dude you really push in
Santa Barbara Tiahrt is that your new
this episode of five kids buddy by a
debar use promo code cow and for 50% off
feel personally delicious do anavar
i want an ax bar and I want [ __ ] I
work oh I can't wait like yeah then you
start [ __ ] your face gets weird man
the whole thing is gonna get weird for
me it's gonna be sad
but awesome your life had changed due to
Johanna Varna the head lift what's wrong
with a headland ahead you know I'm
saying it'll be five days of recoup I
had that I had the chance to do it
recently but he's anything funny but
look at when people are left to on their
own look at their kid down there that's
the rock where he might have been 14 but
you see I think he's 14 the Lita's bones
show very big don't look at that broader
show do that 14 and Samoan bro yeah [ __ ]
around
don't kid yourself I'd have to I'd have
to have life-changing diet to be
shredded I gotta act like I'm doing a
competition I don't have to eat tilapia
every [ __ ] it should be big and thick
I feel like it doesn't look bad on you
we've never seen any other weights he
doesn't like back he's got the automat
that's when he first got to bother you
that's when he first got to Hollywood he
lost a shitload awake is that that was
my BOB correct me if I'm wrong that's
kind of master yeah surgery well he had
surgery he's talked about it oh yeah
oh so that's from steroids okay oh he's
done all the right to be name is steroid
named one look at him on the right name
one yeah but hey why not look man I
don't do you have all the dot like I
would understand do if I had a doctor
that would just be like hey I'll come to
your house up this way you take every
Monday I'll run blood so you're a
healthiest you've ever been I would want
to understand do it I hope that service
is out there you're also gonna go soya
it's five o'clock oil it's expensive
five I get they do every San Diego bro
I can't get down there but it will take
at night you and I know romantic
hot tub but I go once every why now
we're drinking wine I had this so funny
we're friends what it's a bar baby let's
do it let's do an aunt of our trip and
sponsored by anavar we'd go down there
and we [ __ ] by la jolla though the
dogs we don't have that longevity
doctors they do they do it you know
longevity doctors they do an exclusive
test we come out dude I won't come my
house and they just run tests like my
guinea pig yeah I am Gary for rocky
three
you never know it's a very complicated
thing I'm not going these and longevity
centers [ __ ] off but it's also a hustle
cuz I didn't take these vitamins it's a
hustle
they'd I went to one of these guys a
long time ago and goes well you're low
on a lot of stuff like oh really like
vitamins I go what's the marker
what's the marker they tell me the
science of where you should be with the
vitamin C it's all look and your
insurance really don't cover it right
it's also super expensive like 6 G's
yeah it's expensive just promise to I'll
get shredded giving them this thing is 5
G's or something but it's an all-day
test and all that and they're like well
it's your life you have to do everything
yeah I wouldn't be I might just come to
the crib oh you know what they say they
go like this you're healthy for a 52
year old that's probably after all that
time I mean we'll dish yourself is oh I
wouldn't mind getting physical I feel
like my physical okay okay I feel like
Cat Cat doesn't care about us games but
you get older just like your eyes get
worse my eyes are compared to
three-year-old since I make my way work
I'll dude since I may be your I can't be
in your nose
me and Mia Rogan were talking about it's
called macular degeneration oh my eyes
are better than theirs but like it's the
world oh yeah here's were thick glasses
yeah know what it's the world pulling
down your face yeah yeah it's the world
pulling down my face now I need a
facelift no you had a head lift I need
it has to be how your face is fine it's
your head just a head lift and get my
head yeah just pull it up pull
everything out
Kat what do you think all right here's
the thing I don't think girls give a
[ __ ] I think just me and Brian give a
[ __ ] yes yeah I don't I honestly don't
care like with Brendan it wouldn't make
a difference in how he liked what I his
attractiveness if he had abs versus his
potbelly now right I got a Clemson it
doesn't matter Billy I'm sorry I
apologize no it wouldn't matter
personally
okay I can [ __ ] tarik up so badly like
this house guys he works out he's such a
beast but I'll just I'll just touch him
cuz here his whole life has been I just
go I go huh I'll talk about dude you
look good I just go and I touch his
belly and he's like he looks at me as i
party ass
you think is a lot of all of us are like
Kirkland has it's just guys on guys
really all have our well also have our
like we all have looks like my dad
window open in our kitchen all of us
have that one thing that weren't secure
about it was like my dad we're in the
pool with my son my dad we're sitting
there it's all crazy still working out
no he has an idea right he goes I get I
can feel that really just goes it's all
quiet my son runs to the bathroom I
guess you still working out me oh yeah
everyday is huh silence nothing else on
it okay just go huh my wife is gonna
[ __ ] kill me for this but I'm gonna
tell her story because she has amazing
genetics you know it's just lucky should
never do [ __ ] but I noticed we were like
I was sitting there and I was I was
there and I noticed that her belly was
oh she's gonna kill me she's got [ __ ]
couch she bloated she was bloated so I
was like I take a [ __ ] no no no never
like that so I go I had to be careful
now I was like something's up and I go
hey man what's glad that she's like no
no no I just thought she was just I was
like I was like I couldn't figure it out
so I I call my buddy and I go to my
buddy I go he's a he's their nutrition
specialist I go so she's blood before I
asked her what do you think it is he
goes is she eating a lot of a lot of
women eat a lot of raw vegetables sure
enough I go hey woody what do you eat
like typically and she does God have
been eating like literally like a whole
like I totally I can two heads over
broccoli dude and the homeboy hold on I
go to visualize I feel front I know she
doesn't I swear to God
she goes I do feel blown and I go you
know what I notice it and you might want
to will it yeah and she's fine now she's
like that she's one of the people that
can just stop doing it and it like a man
goes back to her she's got genetics like
you know [ __ ] superheating two heads
of broccoli a you shouldn't your pants
be you smell like complete taco doodoo
no it's not it's just creates somebody's
that broccoli gets me going keep you hey
stomach though okay and your stuff
broccoli gets me going it does don't you
have a food where you like bite shut it
oh I don't know
wheat and dairy I'll fart onstage
oh dude I'll be on stage well not really
wheels achieve with you you've been fine
oh yeah until later
look don't I eat a bunch of bread like
it and cheese oh oh give me three pieces
of pizza see what happens I'll be on
stage I'll fart like this ready you
gotta wait til I laugh oh it's been
worse their worst I can't [ __ ] do it
if I [ __ ] feed or not me man oh my
god I'm gonna eat beans one day and hang
out with you it's it's out of control I
don't eat legumes lentil broccoli
broccoli alight me up dude they will
[ __ ] wheat and lentil no way broccoli
does it broccoli yeah yeah me food you
guys stay away from chin definitely milk
cheese you love Jesus all right I think
most Asians are lactose intolerant right
you can not get i'm partially lactose
intolerant
i can eat it just not a lot a lot of a
lot of cows are naturally in asia that
makes sense yeah who else is lactose
intolerant the popular a lot of black
people are yeah yep most good population
so certain parts of Africa so the Masai
in in the Sudan they drink a shitload of
milk they run everything than the cow
directly from there are a lot of people
in the bowel to belt that are lactose
intolerant most people are as you get
older the people that are less lactose
intolerant people from Scandinavia
because they live on terry products and
have forever
so they've they've evolved to be you
know to be able to deal with it you
should be veg kid oh sorry too young to
know what's really fascinating what's
really fascinating is tribes in Africa
one that comes that's a that's a hurting
tribe and they're right next to each
other and the other that's not a hurting
tribe the ones that live off their
animals they're they're lactose tolerant
the other ones are good it just makes
sense just your body does yeah its
sights dude how about I'm sure is it
when your turn events the area 51 [ __ ]
yeah good start with that you know Brian
one thing one thing as you get older
your teeth get a little rougher might
start chattering about better teeth to
me now because you
using some yeah and I didn't so my teeth
below okay huh
start looking a little suspect yeah
there start looking a little suspect but
I don't I can have braces so you know
what I went any alternative I need
candid it's an author does who is
licensed okay an orthodontist that's
right yeah you they they they create a
3d preview of what the final results are
like right so they show you what your
teeth look like that's what they're
doing for me cuz I said I'll do it but
you just have to get my teeth you
approved the 3d prefect and then they
create a custom they create custom clear
aligners which straight to me ready to
you know hassle I don't have to go in
any office anything like that crazy and
candy cost sixty five percent less than
braces you can save thousands and have
straighter brighter teeth in the average
of six months so just see ya hello I've
done the alternative and I spent a
fortune I had to go to a dentist and
take that anymore dudes he's amazing and
I'm so excited to get my clear aligners
from candidate and begin to fix this
specially the bottom teeth you're one
step away from getting straighter
brighter teeth to learn more at candid
co.com slash fighter let's use code
fighter to get seventy five dollars off
that's candid co.com slash spider code
fighter for seventy five dollars off
can't wait to fix my cat better to hear
about this oh you wanna love storm oh
the pounds up to a million there's over
a million people say they're gonna do
this
he got it caught on fire so much the
government had to go but well no it's a
it's an actual Air Force Base do not
storm the base you [ __ ] morons how
stupid do you have to be to rush area51
demand answers a to sign up for that B
to actually do it but C to actually
think you're gonna get through a
government official military base yeah
they're gonna light you get someone's
definitely in shot in the face yeah I
mean something Bad's gonna happen the
vent I'll storm a 51 y'all get you
should definitely make sure it's I tell
you what's gonna have the official store
mayor for doing t-shirts it goes they
can't stop all this well yeah they can I
can you know how how many you know how
it's called tear gas you [ __ ] dummies
and water hoses enjoy that alright it's
so easy for him to stop you guys
any guys cool just just drop teargas but
how's that conversation go hey God like
you're trying to convince like let's
take the whole movement you're up their
own thing like hey so we're gonna storm
area 51 cool on my first answer how we
can get in we're just all gonna storm it
no you keep saying that but like how are
we gonna physically get into the
building because it's a government
building and they're gonna come through
area and you get a de Menil nowhere but
it's also a comment Oh secluded just a
block off all that you know they'll see
you coming a mile away
how about your meter 51 they can't stop
all of us what they can do they
definitely can yeah yeah yeah yeah you
you enjoy getting enjoy the water hoses
and tear gas in your face etc keep
scrolling down that's that's where you
guys gonna run huh oh and you don't
think the government can figure this out
huh you think the government seem right
do you oh hey what do you think the
government seem like a million they're
right we can't stop over come check
things out back to that hey everyone
they pulled away the aliens wow I wonder
have such a bad headache yeah your body
you haven't had plain water and over 32
Sarah your sleep schedules nonexistent
you better give me all day know is that
I don't know I thought that was I
thought was about area 61 but don't ever
read that again how crazy is more of a
gag it's more of a gag with the fact
that this so many so many people are
signing up for it means that there's
gonna be a certain percentage that might
actually go oh you know he's gonna show
up about a hundred and twenty out of the
million and they're like what the [ __ ]
dude all right what's the planning like
yeah imagine go that way in the ghost
way yeah flying to [ __ ] Vegas and you
rent a car alright - there's no the 50
where area 51 is in like where is the
closest town he said Las Vegas but if
you're gonna do it don't tell everybody
you gotta catch them off guard bro
everyone knows this catch them off-guard
now to it now it's out that's out that's
out dude now that are gonna know now if
a million of people showed up
unannounced that's the move but now they
know you're already up form do
three miles northwest of Las Vegas it's
a military base ain't nobody gettin in
there click on that Washington POIs post
police Jesus Goods what happens if they
actually show up
I'm telling about 13 people are gonna
show up god dammit chin dude I hope if
someone shows up they have a GoPro on
their face
I'm so interesting how the government
handles it there's block off roads ah
got TV I stopped you away let's damn
blitz Syrians like yeah let me write the
hell cause what happens you have to
drive their stage credit huge traffic
jam get out and walk see what happens to
say or something let's see them
everything go to fire someone said let's
hashtag let's see them aliens the other
thing I pray to God you got I'll make
sure I support this gives me hilarious I
need to entertainment but if you do get
in do you really this what's so funny do
you really think the government's gonna
leave the aliens out if they are there
yeah there you go
we'll meet here this the thing we will
meet up at area 51 alien senators
attraction and coordinate our entry so
that means no one's thought about it if
we not TRO run number two no route to
run we can move faster than their
bullets
if Lazar is telling the truth so Naruto
is an anime and they're like notorious
for running like this you always thought
that one kid in high school who ran like
that like ran from class to class like
[ __ ] this oh they call it no my niece
me I write out my why they thought
Naruto because it's from that show
Naruto oh we had a different name for it
when I was a girl my niece's Jamie's
that were Dawn's off like that it's
hilarious you can't use that word
anymore that we used to call kids a
trend like that watch at all yeah
speaking with watch impose Friday Air
Force the Air Force spokeswoman they
right just want a response said
officials are aware of the event
already you're [ __ ] when asked how
authorities would respond to the
explorers ander said she couldn't
elaborate on the plants yeah cuz I beat
the [ __ ] her she did however issue a
warrant to those ition to try their luck
area 51 is an opening training range for
the US Air Force and we would discourage
anyone from trying to come in to the
area where we trained American armed
forces the US Air Force always stands
ready to protect America and its assets
Jesus Christ
I see how the CIA so so the the
government Americans were told for
decades
area 51 didn't exist at all now the
notion was officially debunked in 2013
when the CIA can first confirmed this
existence through documents obtained in
a public records request by George
Washington University which is what I
was saying there is the the in Freedom
of Information Act you have to have a
very specific reason why you are keeping
things secret of course the government
has secrets but there there is a lot of
information that you can get I don't go
rasili
government chill yeah keeps going down
chin what happens if they were just like
if you do come at us we're just gonna
lie either [ __ ] up yeah come on down
our guys need target practice
Steff signs that suggests those who's
that who enter could subject a deadly
force
dude it's a military base yeah wonder
who seemed to be the hottest girl that
runs at him that's good tits it's great
do you think it's all white people and I
think it's people who are obsessed with
the idea I think it's just like I think
it's just a cool thing to talk about and
sign up for not sign up for your
community because I may have a million
people that I can't even wrap them we
were down to rush area51 creates
merchandise
it's what everybody you you belong to a
community it's cool to be in an online
chat room here's the thing I hope
they're successful Brian what if they
get in there and like that bob lazar
everything said was all true or Baba
Yaga Bob Lazar might have been working
on drones in their infancy to the US
government uses because they were
working on drums forever and not to that
magnitude Oh shoo describe oh yeah that
well of course they were no drones the
drones they use now were in we're in
development a long long time ago so
drones have always been something that
the US military was thinking about so
you know it's it's very possible that he
doesn't working on something that was a
was it drone or it was from the dude
lights from the star I hope I support
this I hope they're successful and get
it done and it comes all true and then
you're gonna look like such a dummy
gotta be so God be awesome what if one
runs out with an alien like we got um
when you see this that documentary on
the inventor and how they tried to fool
everybody but then what happens is the
press once you get these investigative
journalists who had just David they
start sniffing around oh and they can
make their name onyx but how come little
bit of Bob lives on he's a little too
crazy like everybody cares the press
like figure it out yeah nobody came free
just aliens for ya nobody cares who are
you say Ken nothin though if the
smartest people in the world never
mention it like Stephen Hawking's and
and also who else oh yeah both Stephen
Hawkins isn't saying that the government
has UFOs not saying they don't exist or
that aliens don't exist but he's saying
you know there are a lot of those people
that really follow stuff like this and
they don't seem a little is it great but
it's a lot of the guys
don't know anything about aerospace or
anything I hope they're right that's all
I'm saying dude now do we have tea fat
cake you have four shirts coming yeah we
do okay
no we can fence we do you do yeah calm
infants nope didn't do them it's thing
cuz I was very offensive but something
else and if you fo dat fat kid shoes who
makes those shoes dude jump about those
for me or off tool just keep doing what
you're doing you know get on to Anna
barn get ahead yeah what else you got
Jin I did they do make it I hope they
make it man so um there was a couple who
were in Brighton over in the UK they
ended up having oral sex in front of a
bunch of families on a hot day and now
the police are looking for them han I'm
confused here so that's a guy doing a
woman out
no it's amazing those titties she's got
she's barred the itty bitty titty
committee the idiocy Betty's she's just
lying now yeah surfs have a couch licked
look at that yeah so somebody that's a
great Beach nothing like lot stones you
know it's all God's that's hot as [ __ ]
right so they did in that she sucked him
off no so she got she got eaten now and
then after a couple minutes they stopped
they can they start to cuddle and then
he continued again and somebody asked
this photo and it went viral but
apparently nobody on the beach that day
actually reported it to the police until
nobody completely gonna do would you
call the cops
give a [ __ ] no it was like if you had
like Disney I do that like I do
goddamnit
yeah but now police officers are looking
for this couple and do what are they
gonna do justifying a conifer Indies
next move indecent act in public they're
hammered though look at her sipping on
that better oh yeah look at him that
looks uncomfortable I mean you're on the
straight up bronze bro hi I'm Roxanne
just hey how about no one gives a [ __ ] a
that Beach isn't crowded at all really
that looks at like a terrible beach the
beach of all time it looks like your
next can decide you want to go to our
next Aquarius go to a rock quarry and
hang out like what you what else you
guys go
it's never the hot ones who are doing it
is this never the hot ones
unfortunately so a Canadian university
professor has gotten fired because he
told a student who came to him about her
grades being low that if she bought him
lobster and moose meat that he would
raise her grade and she knew that she
she knew that she shouldn't have had
done it but after a couple of days of
thinking she bought him the lobsters and
the moose meat they met at her car so
she could give it to him upon giving him
the meat she he said that they should
also [ __ ] and if she doesn't [ __ ] him
then he won't raise her grades and did
she do it
no she did not that was the final straw
hey dude be happy with your lobster and
moose moose mean it's going the extra
distance now you got a [ __ ] to like
that's your you're reneging on the dude
contract lobster moose meat have a dick
sucked out give her an A - I mean he
probably was like you know lobster and
live because I knew I was not gonna
sleep with instructor but I also did not
want to fail because he made it clear
that if I have sex when I give you a
seat for the lobster a beef for the
moose and an a for a little more all
right well I think he was just trying to
figure out how much he could get away
with and when she actually brought him
the feel like you like dumbass this is a
live lobster yeah let's rock this damn
yep let me eat the lobster let me some
moose me nagging should she not be in
trouble for bringing lobsters and moose
meat recon to me yeah I don't know
but yeah you got fired unless she's in
session I would love to see him and I
love you Cesar I fired what a surprise
wait he got fired he got make these
choices like what I will show it show
the girl on the guy that night no they
never do they'd ever do makes it next
one okay so this story went viral
there's
this girl named Belle Delphine she's a
youtuber who is known for playing video
games in these kind of like cosplay type
of outfits she's known for the pink wig
the like thigh high socks and then the
kitty ears there is a joke amongst her
community where a lot of people will
comment usually it's like guys who like
to watch watch her and like fantasize
about her saying that they would drink
her bathwater and so she came out with a
product called gamer girl bathwater and
she made an Instagram video of her
taking a bath and capping the water into
this little bottle she said she was
gonna sell that she sold about I forgot
how much it was I don't think she's mine
but $30 per like a small bottle of water
and she sold out twice and he's smart
and she's a businesswoman and she's such
a big troll but a lot of people are
getting mad because there's like a small
population of people getting it to drink
and actually like want a piece of her
it's love and somebody actually went out
of their way to take the water and put
it under a magnifying glass to see if
there's any human DNA in it there was no
human being so it's just water off and
people want to have a class-action
lawsuit against you gonna take the bath
like you're gonna sell that [ __ ] at
least she didn't say that it was gonna
be her actual bath water that maybe
product is gamer girl bathwater and she
posted gamer girl bathwater for all you
search the gamer boys I love it she's
chin did you buy some of this water no I
didn't what is she doing click on this
limb she's also known for doing weird
things like eating a raw egg
I'm putting googly eyes look like a bra
I feel sick oh god I bet she swallows oh
god dude I bet she is a [ __ ] you ever
seen a girl eat a raw leg like that B
she's afraid she's hot oh she's hot oh
man I bet so many guys jacked up I never
seen buddy do that I'm looking dude I
bet she will suck the meat off a bone
I would imagine she like supposed to
mean lobsters I have dude if she's get
down to do that
how many how many views to that four
hundred thirty thousand you think he'd
be more though
you think he'd be more she's only 19
years old
oh no she's a [ __ ] I hate the live
octopus I don't think she ate it she had
a dead octopus and she put googly eyes
on it so my pretend I was like her
friend ya know some girls making Bank
though I think she's interesting
dude bath water get that get that ass
water fellas she's killing it though man
she is killing it a hundred percent
she's killing us I feel like like that's
interesting she's doing [ __ ] that I
haven't kind of seen there are also
false articles before she even shipped
out any of her product saying people who
drank her bathroom water got herpes and
it turned out to be fake cuz an account
pretended to be Daily Mail would would
it be weird if I started following her
yeah probably
how old is she 19 she's legal be she
Asian or she white no she's white she's
originally from South Africa kind of
huge fan a little too young for me but
she said I'm a fan I like her business
acumen I like it she's making money
doing [ __ ] like this she's [ __ ] Brian
starts selling bathwater she's
interesting and unique how great would
it be if I started doing this still in
bath waters to put on a peak she has a
ass on her dad she does she's so weird
dude [ __ ] someone showed me oh well I
mean thrown I mean my brother showed me
this video of the you know the best
worker in the world is white girl in LA
no oh my what's her name
Lexi Panther no no I forget what I think
I know you're talking about but I don't
remember her name on the top of my head
yeah hold on Jessica Vanessa no no no no
no no no no no
No let's see Jessica let me text J right
now Brian wants to see the Sun first
what song was she twerking - no no she's
so good hold on Jase take somebody now
hold on hold on it was very cool nasty
nasty nasty Nez is a white girl glasses
Instagram chin one of her videos
recently went viral to the song my type
by Sayyidi that's a great video
nastiness yeah how do you who's not
cutty smell nasty a underscore n a SS
underscore guys to everybody yeah an
underscore and a s Ryan Hall notice
that's the Ryan Hall 4.1 million hold on
hold up go to go to that the second row
middle one she teaches classes on how to
twerk she's she's super hot oh dude she
is he's so good she's delicious
she teaches classes dude look San
Francisco is crazy thanks for coming out
cuz she this all she does she teaches
how to do this she's that
yeah yeah it's for fitness now so it's
almost like this generation Zumba yeah
you ever tried to work tension of the
exhausting dude she is diet brian has a
huge erection how ridiculous is that
guys give me a minute
I don't see anything like I see a little
more easy I just want to make sure
you'll see anything crazy chin that's
cuz it's not a do unique chins off I
mean what is this the car how is this
different from other girls dancing that
she's really really good at her control
her ass g7 it's her control yeah did
control of her cheeks is amazing yeah
yeah let him L know she's pretty though
I just come from Cal who's obsessed with
a girl who ate an egg and went dude I'm
really proud of her she's doing a lot of
fun stuff
it's very interesting and the picture
was like their business everything was
the same sir yeah but not the girl
teaching seminars losing weight she's
done she's pretty bad dude
yeah like the cornrows some think that's
dude look at that
well they meet hey that's a buddy let's
go ahead and bring that up which one for
action the mesh there we're gonna make
sure this one right I don't know
that's a mesh I mean that's a great ass
right some would say the bathroom god
bless chins up feelin her no she's
definitely a nice ass but I don't see
the what's different you don't see
that's like special compared to other
girls that are doing this I don't know
okay yeah that was made an art form out
of a dude and she teaches you how to do
this yeah you shut up Brennan let's
change this okay that looks interesting
yeah yeah cuz that's so easy
that's too bad that'll be fun dude that
looks like two two more hands
dwarves wrestling under us under a
blanket all right I guess so I've
educated you [ __ ] on nastiness all
right so wonderful my never taste her
friend be high so a worker at a Dairy
Queen ended up getting fired because her
manager made a mistake her manager took
a phone order where a mom was getting a
birthday cake for her 25 year old
daughter who loves Moana untie Roenick
Lee the 25 year old loves Moana
the mom orders the cake over the phone
and the manager who's taking the order
thought she said marijuana honest and so
a the manager game I sit on my little
pony I know that's what the manager okay
though that was the exact design that's
a manager okayed and the girl who's
working there at that time made the cake
and the manager gave it to the mom later
on the mom brought it home I guess she
didn't look at it before she left they
opened it up the 25 year old girl saw it
was like what the hell is this
and her mom was angry too and the girl
who made the cake ended up getting fired
manager that's not fair later on a
different manager came out and tried to
get her her job back but she didn't want
it cases y'all my mama got me a Milani
cake and these [ __ ] thought she said
marijuana case funniest [ __ ] an honest
mistake in pretty good work - yeah
you're good - great that [ __ ] highs
[ __ ] my little pony god that's hilarious
but yet now that girl is out of a job
unfortunately she should be she should
get a [ __ ] raise what else you got
that made me laugh this right here you
see this KFC exploded out of nowhere
ya know check it out no one's in there
but it's completely gone now within like
a second what yeah
what luckily no one was hurt no one was
killed or anything and this is just a
surveillance cameras catching it boom
it's just double iterated little iterate
on its own that was the main one the one
in the beginning what what why did they
they're investigating it still but it's
most likely due to a gas thing you know
some do with gas but the things
instantly [ __ ] you know you'd be dead
gone once I see me at KFC have a hot I
never see him yeah that's crazy though
pretty tasty I feel like Popeyes is the
way - yeah you want chicken Popeyes is a
little clean like KFC himself wins less
himself Popeyes I have not Mother's Day
yeah sounds still I've heard that the
red beans and rice that they have is
also is like one of the best meals ever
its side dishes good you have to be you
know you don't eat that [ __ ] no I've had
it before yeah 1974 74 when I open first
what else you got this small dude that's
making waves right now he's called the
angry angry bagel guy have you seen this
video of him kind of losing it inside a
single shop no I'll just play this for
you first in Long Island
the great why is it okay for women to
say oh you're five feet are dating sites
we should be dead that's okay
who's he talking to people behind him
and the people at the counter why is he
going off he sees like he's been around
a lot of different places and he always
sees people kind of talking talking
about him being tiny some people would
just ask him how tall he is right away
he's very very small but let me see
though he's five he's like picking up on
little things and this guy that guy
attack like I shouldn't have attacked
him what the [ __ ] you like to do [ __ ]
when someone actually does something
I'll go oh how could he do that [ __ ]
you asked for it you said hit me do
something when the guy goes all right he
is desperately unhappy now what what's
he saying here this is funny cuz Milan
everybody I'll beat you sir he's he
gonna fight in line he has like a
YouTube channel to where he goes through
different places and then he calls out
the people that made fun of them oh
there you go it's all fake right yeah
yeah he's not fake but I'm saying like
you this just an act he's doing this to
give attention and then finding
especially in [ __ ] New York finally
when you go do something I guess okay
let's hear I'm here it's very long but
in a nutshell this guy do anything for
nine minutes in a nutshell he just said
that he got tired of people just making
fun of him he's he's like this what do
you call it the voice of for people that
can't defend themselves and stuff like
that and advocate something he's a
superhero superhero for short piece a
superhero for the small and he said he
when he lost it after what happened
he took a bat and went out to the woods
and then he hit a tree yeah and
the bat ricocheted off the tree and hit
his leg and hurt himself he said was a
miniature Yankee think he's bad a
miniature Yankees back oh no this is a
comedian guy or whatever he's not doing
well he also looks like ratatouille so
this isn't good let's just move on right
this is hilarious like a human mouth I'm
so hot it's soaked this voice is funny -
it's funny he's like good that [ __ ]
Deus up there being that kidding
all right yeah like you can't talk like
that now there has to be some
repercussions now I'm glad the guy
didn't just cold-cocked him right in the
stupid face the guy just tackled I was
like what the [ __ ] you doing mm-hmm all
right next one this is what made me feel
bad about that dude that got shot in the
face when he was robbing the fireworks
store this guy robbed did this shop
right here and he gave him the money
back changed his mind
demanded money from the cash here but
then I guess I know change your heart
change your mind said I'm not gonna hard
to change your mind said I'm not gonna
do it the brazen bandit backed out what
could have easily been a couple hundred
dollar money grab
boiled by the robber himself that way
couple hundred dollars uh-huh what
happened because he actually had the
money in his hand so basically it was
all a couple hundred dollars and he told
the guy the owner of the shop that he
had his daughter needs a kidney
transplant he needs money for that so
then when he had like - like - or
whatever hundred dollars in his pan he
was like this is not nothing but
$200,000 that's a bummer so the police
department they do want to find him to
punish him but as at the same time they
want to find him to help him not to if
his daughter really is suffering from
he's gonna do time that's what's gonna
happen
you know we can walk in with a gun yeah
the gun part it's very sad what's going
on I mean it's a bummer figured out well
I lost all the names you're my hostage
you to that story took all the energy
out of us really give us a chin damn it
let's see you let me take no no give it
I guess get what you have some good ones
well this one I thought was really good
this uh Mississippi Canada knee today
what this is funny okay so he he does
because of the whole me to move in and
everything this female reporter wanted
to go on like a
sixteen hour car ride with with this guy
oh yeah and he said as long as you bring
a male companion with you yes you know
you know so nothing happens we're we're
gonna be in my spare not in our car it's
wrong so that's fair
now people are mad at of course people
are mad around especially the girl she
said that was sexist and stuff like it
goes no I'm just he doesn't he doesn't
this day and age anything he does could
be misconstrued you really gay if Trump
is getting in trouble for going grabbing
the girls jobs in kiss here on did you
see that video oh my god he's raped a
few yeah but in this he's like and she
goes we'll see in the White House and
they're like she's suing him for battery
look you like oh my god
anyways um I'm on this guy's side too
yeah for sure I don't sergeant leaguer
won't take a picture of that with a girl
unless there's a guy in it for you P
Diddy is considering bringing back
making of the band and Tempe he needs it
to man that'd be sick what is that I
don't remember that it's not for you no
no but did any bands get formed as they
did yeah no they did but they did last
day all that unless at all I remember
this is a great show daily this is a
clip from it
oh this is the best club yeah let me
turn the water on and align this apart
so these guys are battling why is there
so many people
the words that I could say to make you
come home yeah
seemed so long ago you walked away
things thing down those things cringing
he's singing towards him like West Side
Story he's pretty good it kind of shakes
me up a little bit
[Music]
how about the guys in the back acting
tough these guys are great
this is though it's so fun you fought
look at P Diddy check this up ask
anyways they're just battling that's
[ __ ] very very funny remember it
varies a cop bad you guys wanted to like
baddies on y'all [ __ ] need to walk
from Manhattan to Brooklyn go go give me
my favorite cheesecake
you gotta make in two hours that's funny
to walk [ __ ] that it was well that's
what one person said not in the band
anymore how bad you want it
God that shows classic what if it still
be good now that it's awesome if you do
this now it's not gonna go well if it's
the vivitrol and they make it funny like
this it'll be fun to watch just how like
it's fine you want there's no longevity
in that no has to be taken these haven't
people take a vote though if you use
enough people fun to go for that get the
same people vote for fifty one thing to
do this what else yes that's pretty much
it alright man well there it is Ryan I'm
off to Indy dude how are you yeah buddy
what's this weekend Danny nap is helium
Indianapolis and we just had some new
dates but Indianapolis Thursday Friday
Saturday that's this Thursday Friday
Saturday that I'm in Nashville those
tickers are almost sold out Nashville
Zanies then I'm in the one of my
favorite clubs helium Portland yeah and
that is August 15 to 17th and now I'm in
Houston as well in August those tickets
will be available soon and then Denver
gets chief now though in DT vk.com and
we're dropping new merch tomorrow on t
fat K calm love it Spokane thanks for
coming out
this weekend what a blast San Francisco
this Friday oh wow this is it for a
while for me cuz I gotta start shooting
my TV show San Francisco this Friday at
Cobbs Saturday Friday Saturday come out
and see me we're coming in strong
coming in hot and I'm excited so god
bless you guys alright
is that it yeah you guys gonna close the
show yeah we do man oh because we're
gonna go storm area 51 with everyone
posted out goes alright
mm this the fun kid route